[Music]
did you really
doing how famous you are like as an
african-american male that's who you are
you know it doesn't matter
what what your job is what your name is
and i think being able to wear blue
extra shows like i kind of had my hands
up as well just kind of like look hands
up don't shoot you know i'm so tired of
seeing this we're tired we're tired and
everybody's tired of it so for me
to make that statement i think was just
something i really wanted to do and i
think as african americans male or
female
who were sick and tired of being able to
be afraid
i think that's something i really wanted
to
is think 33. tonight's presentation of
the national anthem
has been recorded and sung by a
transformational youth organization
in the african-american community well
we knew
we were going to be the first game we
would have an opportunity to make a
statement
the biggest thing was just finding
something we all do together
and i brought it to them and i was like
look this is what we want to do and you
know credit to
everybody that was a part of it we
appreciate the support it's the first
and i'm proud to be part of this week
every day that i'm here i get the
opportunity to hear players talk about
things they care deeply about
the changes they want to see in the
world they are so passionate about so
many things it's not just basketball
it's really amazing to be a part of
i love empty buses it's a very weird
thing but
i love when i'm the only person in this
side of the huge
just want to field next up houston
rockets taking on the memphis food
please
this is my first time ever watching the
grizzlies in person i'm excited to watch
john maria game time
[Music]
where are you uh i'm in a bubble
[Music]
all right brian is about to be bj
[Music]
okay let's make sure we are framed up i
think that's why it was
important for us to play but i think at
the end of the day
um you know how now is everything so
based on social media so
you know something could be the trend or
you know quote unquote or
the wave and um like the black lives
matter movement and then
three four months later it starts to die
down and
for us you know it's not gonna hit that
three or four months and die down
because we're kind of picking it back up
and
continue to raise awareness
really been so much unity and
conversation um between players and so
now that players are using their voices
it's just about making sure people are
listening and still tuning in
thank you russell thank you sir
appreciate it are those gonna be for
sale
no wow that's crazy okay one more
i'll get you one i would love one i'd
love it which one do you want to play
but they got like 10 different ones no i
love one thank you so much
okay i appreciate you
[Music]
all black people unjustly killed many by
the hands of police
i chose the back that says power to the
people
hey jack so i know i see your hat saying
vote
um you guys have a lot of different
symbolism and signage
on the coaches shoes hats and everything
like that so what have you kind of
learned about yourself
as a coach during this time and what
it's important for you to do for your
guys and for your assistance
well for me as a coach i've learned two
things number one i've always been
extremely political uh but not enough
you know um you know we had a great
speaker uh
recently talked to our team you know one
of he said i don't know how anyone can
say that
they're not involved in politics because
politics are involved in your life daily
lives
whether you want it or not now decisions
are being made
whether you're involved or not so why
wouldn't you be involved that's the
first thing
and the second thing um i hate to say it
i think i'm a
kid no and uh i think i should listen to
the young people
you know i think uh this movement uh is
really
driven by the young and
so my job is to inspire them to vote and
get involved
and then back up and let them do the
talk and us do the listening
i think that's very important in this
movement if we can do that then we don't
just have young people involved in
politics now
but we have people involved in politics
for life and
i think that's very important for us
game one it has arrived the nba
has returned we're tipping off with jazz
taking on the pelicans zion williamson
is playing he's back on campus i can't
wait i have waited for this day
let's do it
[Music]
we can't touch it i'm sorry
i truly believe that
athletes have a huge platform because
other people have platforms that we all
can use together give back to our
community to be able to educate
our people that's something i believe in
something that i've been doing since day
one
and i continue to do it to be able to
bridge and close that gap
i don't think that you know kneeling or
um
putting on a t-shirt from me personally
is the answer
i feel like for me black lives are
supposed to give the gospel
our lives are supported through the
gospel that we all like i said have
things that
that that we do our own sometimes it
gets into a place of point of fingers
above which wrong is worse
and who's wrong so i feel like the bible
tells us that we're all
we all fall short of we all fall short
of god's lord
and that intended thing you know whoever
will humble themselves and
seek god and repent of their sins that
we could
see it in a different light i'm happy
i'm getting you at the picnic
[Music]
six
i miss an amazing feeling um
to see how far we've come and we still
have so much more to go
it's an amazing feeling to see that we
are step we are taking steps in
in a positive direction and we just got
to remember that it's not finished the
job isn't done yet
we just got to continue to do what we
can to use our platform to let everyone
know that
this is something that's not temporary
you know this is something that we will
continue to do
until we're answered what is it that you
would like to see from the owners that
would make you feel like they get it
uh just some acknowledgement i think
that's a huge part of taking some
ownership
that you know half of our league i mean
eighty percent our league is
african-american men and uh they need to
make sure that they
voice that to us show their concerns
show that they're supporting
the things they want to do for our
communities for our people
especially now more than ever it's
something that
i think is very very important
especially in the honors
should take hours of that finish the
sentence for me
black people are probably beautiful um i
think
you know obviously that goes much more
into
much more in depth than just a physical
um you know
mentally i think we're um you know
growing your race who's smart
you know who don't get uh
it's just do you know obviously but
you know we're real racist it's just
beautiful
so chris i know you guys want awareness
and you want change
but once this orlando campus has
finished what will had to have happened
for you to say we were successful
in that uh that's a great question
that's a great question i think the more
we all
continue to get educated you and
coming down here what we have
opportunity to do is use our collective
voices
obviously to spread the message but we
also get a chance to educate each other
whatever it may be whether it's
financial literacy whether it is police
reform whether it's
uh education whether it's htcu guys can
start to build together that's what
we've been talking about we need to
uh we need to unite becoming united
force and a lot of this action that's
going on so
i'm not the one to determine this but
it's just things that that i like to see
the game was great we won by two by the
end of the day bryant brianna taylor's
killer but still free there are so many
different things that we can honestly
talk about i'm going to continue to talk
about brianna taylor
if that's near and dear to me i'm
keeping on the forefront of people's
minds you know and i think they
wanted to do something as well and just
being able to bring that to them and
being able to do it
just showed how collectively as a group
and as a league we're going to continue
to keep that
on everybody's mind lebron you talked
about what you want next for brianna
taylor in terms of justice but what do
you want next in terms of
us in terms of americans what does an
improved america
look like to you um
i mean it's a great question and it's
something that um
i i rationalize and think about it every
single day
you know what what's next what can i do
next to make an impact in our
communities
um you know not only for for my people
but also for
for america in general um you know
obviously justice for brianna taylor
is number one on all of our lists right
now because we just
know the story we know how
how uh this just crazy
what went on with that situation and how
horrific it is so
um but for us as a as america to to get
better
um you know that's the question that we
we kind of tinker with every day and
it's something that i play with in my
mind every day and listen to the people
around me and also
notice to my family things of that
nature but um
you know the conversations people
sometimes are just afraid to have a
conversation
and and i think the best one of the best
things in life is communication
power to the people black lives matter